إذن ، ما وجهة النظر الأمريكية التي
انضممت إلي الآن هو
المتحدث السابق باسم وزارة الخارجية جون كيربي الموجود
في واشنطن ، أعتقد أن جون كيربي مرحبًا بك
في البرنامج ،
لقد سمعت إبراهيم كيلين
وسمعته يقول أعتقد أن ما يمكن أن يفعله الأمريكيون
هو أولاً وقبل كل شيء.  تعرف على إزالة كل
تلك الأسلحة وإيقاف تلك
الجماعات من الوصول إليها ، فمن المحتمل أن يكون ذلك
جيدًا لا أعتقد أنه ليس
مسيحيًا على المدى القريب لسببين
أولهما جميع الأسلحة التي تم
توفيرها للمقاتلين الأكراد وهي
ليس فقط المقاتلين الأكراد ، إنها
قوى سوريا الديمقراطية التي تضم
العرب أيضًا ، إنها أسلحة صغيرة وذخائر صغيرة من
هذا النوع ، ورقم
ثاني ، القتال ضد داعش في سوريا
لا يزال حياً إلى حد كبير ، أعتقد
أن المتحدث كان مخطئًا عندما
قال  تم القضاء على داعش في سوريا ، ولم يقل
أحد أنه بالتأكيد ليست هذه
الإدارة وليس الجيش ،
لا تزال هناك جيوب من مجموعات داعش
داخل سوريا ، ومعظمها الآن في منتصف الطريق.  إذا
كانت البلاد وإلى الجنوب من
منطقة منبج ، لكنهم موجودون هناك ولذا ما
زلنا بحاجة إلى الشراكة مع
القوى الديمقراطية السورية على الأرض
لملاحقة بقية داعش هناك في سوريا ،
لكن ماذا يمكنك أن تفعل لتهدئة مخاوف الديوك الرومية
؟  يعني أنك سمعت ما قاله الرماد
كارتر وزير الدفاع الذي
كان هناك مع الرئيس أوباما بينما
كنت المتحدث باسم وزارة الخارجية ،
ما الذي يمكنك فعله وما لا
ينبغي عليك فعله لطمأنة
تركيا نعم أعتقد أن هذه
الإدارة تستطيع  بذل المزيد من الجهد لطمأنة
تركيا ، وأعتقد أنهم يحاولون ذلك ،
ولذا فهم موجودون هناك الآن ، فهم
يحاولون معرفة إلى أين تذهب الديوك الرومية
في هذه العملية في عفرين ، والآن نعرف
ما يقولونه وهو يتعلق
بأمن حدودهم ولكننا لا نفعل ذلك.  لا أعرف
ما هي النتيجة أنهم لا يعرفون بالضبط إلى أي
مدى سيذهبون ، هل
سيضعون قوات الاحتلال هناك
، هم فقط سيفعلون ذلك
في الهواء ثم يتراجعون لذلك
تحاول الشكل  إعادة الخروج بالنتيجة
أن الهدف هنا بالنسبة لتركيا والرقم
الثاني يحاولان العمل خلف
الكواليس دبلوماسياً لطمأنة تركيا
بأننا نتفهم
مخاوف حدودهما المشروعة على حدودهما ولكن
هناك طرقًا أفضل لمعالجتها
من الهجمات عبر الحدود مثل  بصفتي
الشخص الذي يفعلونه ، أود أيضًا
أن أوضح نقطة هنا ، فأنت تعلم
أن هواء عفرين هو الطريق
شمال غرب سوريا ، وهي
منطقة كردية تاريخية كان الأكراد
دائمًا هناك عبر التاريخ ، هذا
ليس هذا ليس كذلك  جيب من
الهجمات الإرهابية من حزب العمال الكردستاني الآن لا يمكنني أن أشكك في
أنه ربما لم تكن هناك
ضربات عبر الحدود من عفرين لكنها
ليست بؤرة ساخنة لحزب العمال الكردستاني كما
تعتقد أن التفكير الحالي
من الجانب الأمريكي
كريستيانا هي أن الأتراك اختاروا هذه
المرة هذا المكان
لمحاولة دق إسفين بين الولايات
المتحدة والقوى الديمقراطية السورية
التي نعمل بشكل جيد مع شرق
نهر الفرات لذلك نحن  هنا هل تعتقد أن
هذا يذهب وقبل أن أسألك جيدًا ،
هل تعتقد أن هذا ينتهي بمباراة إطلاق نار
بين تركيا
وبالتبعية الولايات المتحدة لا
أعتقد ذلك ، لذا لا أعتقد أن أيًا من الجانبين يريد
أن يصل إلى ذلك  النقطة أعتقد أن ما
يحدث هنا هو حسابات سياسية من
قبل كل من تركيا وروسيا لتقليل إن
لم يكن القضاء تمامًا على الوجود العسكري الأمريكي
داخل سوريا ، يريدنا الجانبان
الخروج من تركيا ، ويستخدم الأتراك هذا
لدق إسفين بيننا وبين قوات سوريا الديمقراطية لأنهم إذا
اعتقدوا  هم وأنت رأيتم على الأرجح
كريستيان أن قوات سوريا الديمقراطية قد قالت بالفعل
إنهم قد يأتون لإنقاذ أخيهم
في منتدى من شأنه أن يأخذهم
بعيدًا عن القتال في داعش ضد داعش
حيث نحتاج إليهم والمركز الثاني الذي
تشاهده روسيا تستخدم هذا  كثيرًا
لمحاولة دق إسفين بين تركيا
في الولايات المتحدة كما أشرت بحق
اثنين من حلفاء الناتو